bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 29 avril voici
les titres de cette édition on met
l'ile-de-france va bénéficier de 2
millions de doses files heures et
moderna supplémentaires annonce de
l'agencé régionale de santé pour
permettre l'accélération de la campagne
de vaccination et notamment dans les 16
centres yvelinois reportage a créé
pierre site rural mais maillon au
combien important dans la lutte contre
le coc vie de 19 200 injection ils sont
réalisés chaque jour demain c'est la
journée mondiale des mobilités de
l'accessibilité à cette occasion
l'association apf france handicap mène
une semaine d'action nous en parlons
avec notre avec son représentant
yvelinois christian lelièvre aujourd'hui
9 personnes sur 10 éprouve des
difficultés d'accessibilité lors de
leurs déplacements une problématique qui
va bien au delà du handicap
et puis le projet d'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt avance un groupement
de cinq entreprises a été choisi pour
mener les travaux
le site accueillera les épreuves de vtt
aux jeux olympiques 2024 et nous
refermerons ce journal au château de
versailles ou la chapelle royale et le
cabinet du roi ont été restaurés
les obsèques de stéphanie mon fermé se
sont déroulés en fin d'après midi à
saint léger en yvelines la fonctionnaire
de police a été tué lors d'une attaque
au couteau commissariat de rambouillet
vendredi dernier est la cérémonie dans
la plus stricte intimité a débuté à 16
heures 30 par une messe dans ce village
où elle résidait emmanuelle et brigitte
macro ont assisté à la cérémonie le
président de la république qui avait
fait déposer une gerbe de fleurs dès le
matin tout comme des riverains qui ont
pu déposer quelques bouquets le secteur
autour de l'église a ensuite été bouclée
à partir de 14 heures un registre de
condoléances sera accessible en mairie
dès demain vendredi stéphanie mon fermé
avec 49 ans ont lancé d'ailleurs un peu
plus sur la cérémonie d'hommage national
qui se déroulera demain à vendredi à
rambouillet
stéphanie m'enfermer recevra la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume la cérémonie
sera présidée par jean castex et en
présence de plusieurs ministres
elle débutera à 10h30 sur la place andré
tôt mais à quelques mètres du
commissariat de police où s'est déroulée
la tacc l hommage doit durer une heure
le premier ministre y tiendra un
discours avant une minute de silence et
une marseillaise pour clôturer la
cérémonie elle nous reviendrons sur
cette cérémonie d'hommage national dans
notre émission du 7-8 week-end demain
soir sur tv 78 où il sera également aux
questions du calendrier du déconfinement
annoncées ce soir par emmanuel macron
dans la presse régionale
deux millions de doses supplémentaires
de finder et moderna pour
l'ile-de-france en mer annonce cette
semaine de l' agence régionale de santé
et des doses qui vont pouvoir profiter
directement au centre de vaccination
notamment les 16 dans les yvelines est
dont celui de crespières située dans la
communauté de communes de gally moudre
le site est aux antipodes du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines un
centre rural qui assure la vaccination
de 200 personnes par jour le reportage
sur place de mélanie poké et de bixente
maria senti steban c'est super
sympathique j'ai bien organisé on attend
très peur non ça se passe très bien
beaucoup plus petit que le vaccinodromes
de saint quentin en yvelines
le centre de vaccination de crespières
est l'un des seize complexe yvelinois un
centre rural qui assure depuis le 10
mars un rythme régulier d'injection on
accueille ce fantastique du des
personnes très sympa
des explications parfaite hier nous
étions quatre mille personnes
donc en six semaines et à partir la
semaine prochaine nous allons passer le
cap des 5000 la particularité a créé
pierre hormis les médecins infirmiers le
personnel administratif et bénévoles ils
se relaient six jours sur sept de sorte
à être 8 sur place je me suis proposé
quand aventure a commencé début mars je
me suis proposé quand il ya eu un appel
à bénévoles par notre part notre
première adjointe moi je fais tous les
samedis tous les samedis matins et et si
on a besoin après plus tard pour le
samedi après midi
j'essaierai d'être volontaire également
et puis ça prend quelques heures
également parce que je m'occupe d'eux
également de gérer les tout ce qui est
personnel médical
accueil assistance aux personnels de
santé et même récupération des doses de
vaccins nécessaires à l'hôpital de
versailles un engagement local
inattendue lors de la mise en place du
projet ce qui est absolument
extraordinaire dans notre histoire c'est
que c'est des bénévoles de notre
intercommunalité
petite intercommunalité de 24 mille
habitants et j'ai 150 bénévoles qui se
sont présentés que je ne connaissais
absolument pas et qui ont décidé de
venir à mes côtés pour permettre qu'une
fonctionnement de ce centre
la rs a d'ores et déjà prévu de doubler
les doses de vaccins livrés au centre
400 injections par jour pour une moyenne
de 2000 par semaine et on apprend par
ailleurs ce jeudi que dans le centre de
vaccination d'une autre commune à poissy
des créneaux seront ouverts ce samedi
1er et dimanche 2 mai y seront réservés
aux personnes de plus de 55 ans qui
pourront se faire vacciner sans rendez
vous au chapitre politique les élections
régionales et il ne manquait plus que
l'officialisation valérie pécresse est
candidate pour un second mandat à la
tête de l'île de france est la
présidente sortante est libre de la
région l'annoncé hier mercredi dans les
colonnes de nos confrères du parisien
rer vélo rénovation des lycées aides à
l'achat de véhicules électriques
mutuelles régionales sont parmi ses
priorités affichées pour la campagne
face à valérie pécresse audrey pulvar
soutenue par le parti socialiste à
clémentine autain pour la france
insoumise et jordan bardel avec le
rassemblement national julien bayou avec
europe ecologie les verts et laurent
saint martin pour la république en
marche scrutin des régionales
au programme les 20 et 27 juin prochain
est la journée mondiale des mobilités de
l'accessibilité est programmée ce
vendredi 30 avril à cette occasion à
verneuil-sur-seine des habitants se sont
réunis pour dénoncer l'accès aux soins
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap s'était organisée par
l'association apf france handicap dans
le cadre d'une semaine d'action qui est
lancée partout en france on en parle
juste après avec mon invité mais
regardez d'abord ce sujet de mickaël
miro une journée de sensibilisation sur
le handicap à verneuil-sur-seine un
petit groupe de personnes s'est réunie
sur la place du marché suite à l'appel
de l'association apf france objectif de
cette mobilisation dénoncé l'accès aux
lieux de soins on voudrait mettre le
doigt sur le chantier qui est devant
nous pour parler d'avenir parce que ce
qui est derrière nous
on laisse derrière nous de parler
d'avenir et essayez d'imaginer ce que
sera le monde de demain en termes
d'accès aux soins
cette journée était également l'occasion
pour ces personnes en situation de
handicap de parler de leurs difficultés
au quotidien je ne peux sortir de chez
moi qu'en empruntant la chaussée parce
que beaucoup de bateaux n'existe pas ou
ou entre il ya des passages pour piétons
et de part et d'autre ce sont des
trottoirs n'y a pas d' abbey soeur c'est
dangereux oui oui oui
selon l'association apf france 9
personnes sur 10 se rencontrent des
difficultés dans leurs déplacements
parmi eux des mères de famille avec
leurs poussettes des enfants encore des
personnes âgées
des chiffres qui ont interpellé les élus
locaux nous mettons à verneuil en place
une commission d'accessibilité pour
associer les associations et puis plus
globalement les personnes qui sont
volontaires afin de travailler sur ces
questions et d'améliorer l'existant et
puis aussi de réfléchir à comment on
peut travailler
l'avenir de nos infrastructures de nos
lieux qui vont être aménagés d'autres
actions de ce type pourraient être
organisées dans les prochains mois on
continue la discussion avec christian
lelièvre bonsoir vous êtes le
représentant départemental de
l'association ap france handicap dans
les ive il l'association je le disais
est à l'origine de cette semaine de
mobilisation et d'action pour
l'accessibilité marche à taxer le nom de
cet événement et ce chiffre qui a été
rappelé dans le reportage 9 personnes
sur 10 éprouve des difficultés et
d'accessibilité lors de leurs
déplacements c'est le résultat d'une
enquête qui a été menée auprès de 12
mille français concerné ou non par le
handicap c'est à dire que
l'accessibilité c'est un enjeu de
société ça va même bien au delà des
personnes en situation de handicap
absolument et quand on a quand vous avez
un escalier que vous voyez les parents
qui sont en train d'escalader l'escalier
avec le bébé dans un endroit et la fête
dans une autre main c'est c'est un vrai
problème d'accessibilité effectivement
oui ça concerne c'est problématique
concerne une en 9 français sur 10 km une
ans
france handicap a donc lancé cette
semaine de mobilisation il ya des
actions partout en france et c'est le
cas on l'a vu dans ce reportage à
verneuil-sur-seine pourquoi mener
justement une action ce jour là c'était
mardi à verneuil sur seine donc en fait
les toutes les manifestations se
déroulent sur une semaine et chaque jour
un thème
donc en fait et ce mardi nous nous
sommes rencontrés donc c'était la
journée consacrée l accès aux lieux de
soins que parfois je pense et nous avons
choisi de traiter ce thème dans notre
ville de verneuil sur seine c'est pas
pour dire que cette ville est moins
accessible aucune autre de ses pour
montrer peut-être le chantier qui est
devant nous et raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs nous avions invité les élus
et le maire nous a rejoint le remercie
et qui plus est donc quand on a vu on a
bien constaté que notre nerfs ou étaient
partie prenante dans ce projet et
voulait se donner les moyens de réaliser
toutes les améliorations nécessaires
donc voila c'était cette journée de
mardi consacrée ou lie de soi verneuil
sur seine où je le précise vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition alors
les objectifs de cette semaine d'action
on imagine sensibiliser le public peut
être aussi dénoncé ce manque
d'accessibilité
on imagine aussi alerter les pouvoirs
publics ont et à la proche de prochain
scrutin régional départemental il ya les
élections présidentielles également
l'année prochaine donc effectivement
c'est c'est une période idéale que la
période électorale pour pouvoir
alimenter faire tourner le moulin
promesses de nos candidats aux élections
là pour les obliger peut-être à dire des
choses et après pour nous prendre acte
des promeneuses qu'il nous faut et puis
de les emmener sur le terrain de
l'accessibilité universelle
en fait je le rappelle ça concerne quand
même l'ensemble de
la population d'1 français sur vis tu
veux dire c'est quand même quelque chose
de des normes
donc voilà donc nous nous élus je
l'espère on se saisir de ce sujet là
venons pas à la destination uniquement
des personnes en situation de handicap
je le répète oui mais de l'ensemble de
la population française en fait parce
que chaque chaque cas est étudié et à
prendre en compte
en fait et regarder comment on peut
améliorer les choses on n'est pas l'idée
c'est pas d'aller tout cas c'est d'aller
tout changé de mains et comme je disais
à notre élu maire c'est que on a un jour
pour en parler et peut-être pas assez
d'un mandat pour tout faire bien sûr
mais c'est le moment ou jamais peut-être
de se saisir de ce sujet là et de le
mettre sur l'avant scène pour que
essayer de faire en sorte que les choses
avancent et justement sans trop rentrer
dans les détails mais que dit la loi
aujourd'hui sur cette thématique de
l'accessibilité au niveau on imagine que
ça va pas assez loin encore
ah mais moi je vous dirai pas que la loi
ne va pas assez loin bien sûr qu'il ya
toujours matière à discuter sans la loi
mais aujourd'hui on a un arsenal de lois
et d'obligations l'a certainement de
quoi faire une encyclopédie
sauf qu'il ya personne pour la lire donc
le sujet aujourd'hui je bien sûr faux il
ya des choses à améliorer mais déjà on
va pouvoir appliquer tous que la toux
tous les engagements toutes les
suggestions qui ont été faites au
travers des lois depuis 1975 en vous le
disiez c'est une semaine avec plusieurs
thématiques abordées mardi à vannes
vernay sur scène c'était des actions qui
avaient a trait à la question de l'accès
aux soins les autres thématiques
abordées quelles sont elles
et si j'ai bien compris le principe
c'est à chaque fois de porter des
propositions pour séjourner justement
thématiques oui effectivement on excuse
et le régime blanc là sur les autres
thématiques pense que j'étais vraiment
mobilisé ses positions c'est que
vendredi par exemple il y à l'accès aux
loisirs aux loisirs à savoir spectacle
il y a
on a interpellé lundi on a consacré la
journée pour interpeller les élus en
place à savoir le président du
département
les présidents de des communautés
d'agglomération et les candidats aux
élections ainsi que naturellement des
députés voilà donc
on retrouve en tout cas le programme
détaillé aujourd'hui nous avons consacré
j étais donc aujourd'hui mais avant de
consacrer la journée pour les yvelines à
l'accès aux transports en commun
d'ailleurs nous avons passé une journée
dans la ville de conflans avec transdev
pour tester et les accessibilités donc
des transports en commun à savoir les
arrêts bus la mise en conformité des
arts et donc à conflans sainte honorine
nous a présenté un certain nombre d'arh
est devenu ce sur des parcours des gay
qui sont aujourd'hui accessibles et on a
pu se rendre compte que dans l'ensemble
on a plus de 70 % des arrêts de bus qui
sont dit au dehors mais entièrement
accessible ça veut pas dire pour autant
que ceux qui ne sont pas qu'ils
répondent pas aux critères de la norme
ne soit pas accessible malgré tout donc
effectivement c'est ainsi qu'ils ont été
abordés à londres cette semaine et qui
se termine donc demain avec cette
journée mondiale des mobilités et de
l'accessibilité on trouve d'ailleurs
tout le programme sur les liens internet
qu'ils vont s'afficher toutes les
informations sur l'association apf
france et aussi sur cette action marche
attaques qui se déroule jusqu'à demain
vendredi merci christian lelièvre
d'abord été avec nous ce soir
merci qu'en fin de journée avant et je
rappelle que vous êtes le représentant
départemental de la pf france handicap
dans l'actualité également le projet
d'aménagement de la colline d'elancourt
avance le 31 mars dernier la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympique
soli deo a désigné un groupement de cinq
entreprises chargées de réaliser les
travaux de ce site qui accueillera et
des épreuves de vtt lors des jo de 2024
de paris ait beaucoup de réalisations
sont prévues et en plus du côté sportif
le site sera ensuite aussi ouvert au
grand public les précisions de michael
et demi d'euros et de jo ça cale c'est
une nouvelle étape pour la colline
d'elancourt la solide et aux maîtres
d'ouvragé du projet a choisi cinq
entreprises pour aménager le futur site
qui accueillera les épreuves de vtt des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024
nous avons beaucoup avancé entre autres
avec l'architecte spécialisés pour la
création des pistes d'un point de vue
sportif c'est à dire que le tracé des
pistes est arrêté je dis bien des pistes
à dire de la piste de paris 2024
elle-même mais également des pistes
secondaires annexes qui seront ouverts
au grand public une fois que les jeux
olympiques seront passées et puis nous
travaillons aujourd'hui je dis bien que
nous travaillons toujours avec la soli
deo sur les projets d'aménagement 10
millions d'euros d'investissements sont
prévus pour le projet sans constructions
en dur sur le site et avec une portée
écologique pour que de futures familles
sportifs amateurs et promeneurs puissent
s'y balader nous pensons dont les
aménagements pour ce que l'on appelle
l'héritage c'est à dire rendre encore
plus vert et pérenne l'ensemble de tout
ce que vous voyez plantés sur ce site
avec un point culminant à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude
les élus locaux espèrent voir en ce
nouveau lieu un vrai emblème de réussite
de ces jo 2024 il sera ouvert et
accessible
sachant qu'aujourd'hui certes la colline
est ouverte mais elle est difficilement
accessible
il ya des chemins qui sont même je
dirais de dangereux par moment puisque
il s'est quand même assez pentue c'est
compliqué d'y monter et de l'esthétique
n'aura rien à voir avec ce que c'est
aujourd'hui ça demeurera bien entendu le
point le plus haut d'île de france je
vous rappelle que du sommet de la
colline on voit la tour eiffel et on
voit tout paris mais ça sera également
certainement le point le plus
écologiquement respecté qui aura un vrai
bénéfice à la venue des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 pas de date précise pour
les premiers coups de pioche mais en
attendant le département travaille déjà
sur les dispositifs de caméras pour une
meilleure retransmission possible
c'est à l'initiative de l'association
étudiante 1 terrasse aucun bus épicerie
solidaire de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines se déplacent
chaque semaine dans les résidences
étudiantes comme vous voyez sur ces
images tournées aujourd'hui par just
call à montigny le bretonneux
il délivre gratuitement jusqu'à 200
paniers composés de cinq denrées
alimentaires et de produits d'entretien
pour les étudiants en situation de
précarité à l'action étant en
partenariat avec l' agence d'insertion
départementale activity est la tournée
aura lieu les mercredi jeudi et vendredi
de 11h30 à 14h et et 14 heures et ce
pour une durée de quatre semaines on
écoute à ce propos ces interviews
recueillies par jesse williams de nos
confrères de sensations yvelines cette
initiative
elle est allée louable dans le sens où
c'est au pied de la résidence
du coup c'est une bonne chose il ya
enfin j'avais vu d'autres initiatives du
genre mais qui était un peu loin et avec
les études le couvre-feu confinement
tout ça sera toujours évident de se
déplacer de jongler entre tout ça du
coup le fait que ça soit au pied de la
résidence et c'est une très très bonne
chose qu'on n'a pas vu non plus une si
grande explosion de la précarité
étudiante ça elle a compté 1 ça sur mes
skis a exposé ses les étudiants qui
était déjà précaire ils le sont encore
plus et et et surtout surtout c'est le
mal être étudiant en ce moment qui lui a
explosé fortement les jeunes en
situation de précarité concernés par
cette enquête lancée par le secours
populaire des yvelines le but recueillir
les soies et envies des jeunes en vue
d'organiser une journée d'activités
pendant les vacances et les participants
peuvent aussi devenir bénévole pour
participer à l'élaboration du projet les
réponses sont attendues avant le 15 juin
interview express collectées par astrid
bergère
[Musique]
lang était la destination des jeunes de
18 à 30 ans qui sont en situation de
précarité dans les yvelines et qui
partent pas en vacances cet été
on leur demande ce qu'ils voudraient
faire pour vraiment faire un projet qui
correspond à leurs besoins leurs envies
leurs attentes
donc on demande par exemple s'ils
préfèrent la plage le parc d'attraction
des visites culturelles et on leur
demande aussi s'il veulent est partie
prenante du projet en devenant bénévole
dans la création de celui-ci
les décès quand on va essayer d'aller
jusqu'au 15 juin pour répondre au
sondage pour pouvoir ensuite rappelé
tous les haines qu'on proposait d'être
bénévole dans le projet et construire
ensemble
toute l'action l'aider c'est aussi
qu'ils puissent se rendre sur notre page
facebook pour y répondre
donc secours populaire des yvelines ou
sur notre site internet secours
populaire point fr sillage 78 et qu'on
puisse avoir le plus de réponses
possibles pour faire vraiment quelque
chose qui correspond aux besoins et aux
attentes des jeunes
on referme ce journal au château de
versailles les restauration de la
chapelle royale et du cabinet l'angle du
roi sont terminés tous deux ont subi une
rénovation intégrale pour retrouver leur
éclat d'antan et justine brasier est
allé découvrir le résultat sur place une
restauration intégrale c'est ce qu'a
connu le cabinet du roi à cette année
architecture boiseries et ameublement
ont fait l'objet d'une rénovation ou
d'un nettoyage de points inscrits
un état boursièrement de salt et même
pour certains il présentait désordre et
pouvait y avoir des fantasmes important
il y avait quelques lacunes dans des
parties de dormir mais également des
parties sculptées qui était lacunaire
[Musique]
l'occasion de restaurer le meuble
emblématique de versailles mobilier
français du xviiie siècle le bureau du
roi
ce meuble a été nettoyé la série n'avait
pas été démontés je pense depuis sa
construction
donc c'était une grosse opération qui a
été menée à paris dans ce sens qu'on
appelle le c2rmf centre de recherche et
de restauration des musées de france et
qui a nécessité au préalable des
analyses autre chantier de restauration
qui vient de s'achever après trois ans
de travaux celui de la chapelle royale
la charpente du bâtiment étaient abîmées
sculptures vitraux et dorures ont été
restaurés on a vraiment voulu porter
dans la restauration dans son ensemble
donc du faîtage couverture aux ornements
plomb et aux ornements de sculptures
donc les statuts en elles-mêmes ont
porté une restauration assez conséquente
également
au total une centaine de personnes s'est
succédé sur le site pendant le chantier
douze corps de métiers différents
objectif restaurer le visuel d'origine
de la chapelle la d'horreur n'a pu été
refaite depuis depuis 19e et 20e
c'est là aujourd'hui qu'on redécouvre
versailles à sous sont vraiment à
l'inauguration que le 14 a pu voir lors
de son règne ou du projet près de 15
millions d'euros
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]